This is super interesting.
We've got the RNC starting tonight in which
overwhelmingly the case for reelecting Donald
Trump is going to be made by his own family.
Members were going to be hearing how great
Donald Trump is from, yes.
His own vice president, but also from his
wife, Melania Trump, his kids, Ivanka, Don,
Junior, Eric and Tiffany.
And there will be some other speakers, including
that couple from St. Louis, who pointed guns
at protesters.
But even Trump's family isn't unanimously
on board with his reelection.
You already know about Mary L. Trump's devastating
book about him a few weeks ago.
That's Trump's niece.
But there is now leaked audio where Donald
Trump's own sister, Maryanne Trump Barry,
said that Donald Trump has no principles,
that you can't trust him and that he lies
all the time.
Now, this is not some random person who doesn't
know Trump.
This is his sister.
Let's listen to this devastating audio.
And Maryanne Trump, Barry particularly aghast
at the constant lies from Donald Trump.
God gave me and the way God gave me a change
of stories, a lack of preparation, the lying
only.
But he's appealing to the base.
What they're doing with the kids at the border,
I mean, now, right away, right wingers are
focusing on.
Oh, but these recordings were made surreptitiously.
These these were secret recordings.
Now, that's true.
Doesn't change anything.
And notably, these were done surreptitiously,
but not illegally because these recordings
were made in New York, which is a one party
consent state.
What that means is that as long as one party
to the conversation knows there's a recording
being made, it's legal now.
We can debate the morality of it.
I'd argue that the moral imperative to remove
Trump is such that I'm not going to get bent
out of shape by legal surreptitious recordings.
Maybe you disagree with me there.
That's fine.
And now this is where it gets super interesting.
Remember the claim that Trump paid somebody
to take his essay tees for him?
Part of this audio includes Trump's own sister
saying she has knowledge of that.
Take a listen to this.
Please.
Yes, she's right.
I mean, you're in New York City trying to
get him into college.
Gentlemen, before you look at me.
And he went to one year and then he was saying,
he's saying something, isn't it?
That's what I believe.
Now, with twenty two stories.
So there's once again the claim in what Maryanne
Trump, Barry thought was a private conversation.
It was recorded by Marielle Trump saying Trump
paid someone to take his essay tease.
There are more clips.
Let's listen to one more where Marion Barry
Trump, Maryanne Trump.
Barry recalls a conversation where Trump called
to ask her, hey, did you see me on Fox News?
And she said, I don't really watch Fox or
much TV.
And Trump was in crowd.
He couldn't believe, what are you doing?
And she explained that she reads books.
Take a look at this, because if you watch
Fox News, I said no.
Not.
I don't watch much television at all.
Pause.
What do you do?
I read.
Pause.
What do you read books?
You know what, to me?
That that is just what to me is just brilliant
about these recordings are two things.
First of all, Trump's own family sees Trump
the way we do.
And what I mean by that is they know him privately
and still react in the same way that we react
to the public version of Trump, which tells
us that privately, Trump really is that same
person that we see in public.
The unarmed, pathetic, self obsessed, narcissistic
maniac.
It's the same guy.
Now, as far as these recordings changing anything
in terms of election results?
I don't think so.
You know, Donald Trump's base ignores anything
that they don't like.
They probably won't even hear about this if
they do, Del, ignore it.
And in reality, there's nothing here that
we don't already know.
And his base is so cultlike that I don't think
these recordings are really going to do anything
in terms of hurting his election reelection
chances.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
I don't see it making any real big impact.
Maybe the RNC will.
And that's what I want to talk about next